[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is my chat
with the incredible Carrie Kenny she is
incredible I'm so happy that she took
the time to come by I've been a big fan
of hers for a long long time obviously
from Reno 9-1-1 uh Wanderlust which we
talk about quite a bit and anything and
everything she's ever been in Forever
Until the End of Time speaking of which
uh Reno 911 It's a Wonderful Heist is
going to be premiering on Comedy Central
on December 3rd so that means we have
new Reno 911 episodes coming out with
the incredible carry in them obviously
I'm going to say it reprising her iconic
role so be sure to check that out Comedy
Central December 3rd and also I am
currently on tour uh thank you to
everybody that came out to Toronto
Atlantic City in Boston and Chicago next
up is San Francisco Portland Seattle
Atlanta Charlotte and Washington DC
I should be adding more dates and I'm
going to be coming to Vancouver which is
actually where I am right now in case
you're watching the video and noticing
that I am in a hotel room yes I am uh
but I'll be coming here excuse me I'll
be coming here to do stand-up uh shortly
so look for that date it will also be on
petehomes.com so I'm excited for all of
these shows and hope you guys can come
out it is always great when weirdos are
there and if you like this show as I
always say why not try a Peter's pick
I'm going to say Peter's pick this time
Pete's picks things that I actually use
and I actually love speaking of actually
using actually love of course I'm
wearing the perfect jeans right now uh
these are my absolute favorite pants in
the world and no lie this week I needed
a couple new pairs and I went on and
used my own promo code that's how hard
of a Pete's pick this pizza pick is
perfect jeans as you know I I hate a
hard pant I don't understand why we
can't just live in comfortable soft
pants but honestly the problem is they
often don't look very good well enter
the perfect Jean they look great they
look like designer wonderfully stylish
perfect fitting they haven't been slim
they haven't been skinny they have in
all different styles so they look
amazing but they are super soft and made
with flexible fabric that look so good
no one needs to know I got tired of
wearing yoga pants in public like I was
Phil Collins I couldn't pull it off so I
got the perfect Jean and they are the
best pants I've ever owned I've
literally I just rotate through pairs of
perfect jeans I haven't taken them off
since they arrived and that was years
ago and point of fact one of the things
I love about them I'm tired of spending
a good hard-earned money on jeans and
then they they rip they tear they wear
out perfect jeans are the longest
lasting jeans I've ever had in my life
and that's probably because because of
the premium stretch fabric it's two
percent spandex 2.5 percent rayon for
extra comfort and movement that your man
Parts require these jeans stretch so
you're not saying crushed thereby
providing the only true home for your
bone they're so soft they're literally
as soft as a baby's butt and you may
even forget that you're wearing pants
and as I mentioned maximum maximum
durability these are incredibly well
made constructed utilizing utilizing the
highest quality of materials and sewing
techniques to provide you with a product
that is built to last that is facts and
best of all they're not khakis [__] [__]
wearing khakis [__] your khakis spare
your nuts the perfect Gene for the
Perfectly Imperfect men just 60 bucks
when you use code weirdo at checkout at
theperfectgene.nyc liberate your lower
limbs with the one and only perfect Jean
whether you're working with lemons or
lentils a three leaf clover or a big old
Hong and eggplant the perfect Gene has
you covered take a peek at
www.theperfectgene the perfect JEA n dot
NYC that's the perfect
gene.nyc use code weirdo for 25 off at
checkout and show your support for your
body your your zones and for this
podcast the perfect gene.nyc code weirdo
this podcast is also brought To Us by
our friends at Blue microphones do you
love podcasts sure you do maybe you've
been thinking about starting a podcast
maybe you want to record an album or do
voice over for that cartoon series that
you've had kicking around in your in
your noggin that you want to upload to
Youtube well great how do you get going
how do you get sound that is incredible
in studio quality without paying huge
Studio costs well don't worry our
friends at Blue microphones has got you
covered for the first years of this
podcast we recorded uh the first hundred
I don't know on Blues most famous mic
their most simple mic 2 which is the
blue they're all simple but it's like a
standalone blue Yeti USB mic that plugs
straight in your computer and boom I was
off and running starting the podcast
makes it really really easy to sound
great even if you're new to recording
it's the only USB mic that I've also
found that has different settings right
on the back there's a knob for sitting
solo so it's pointing right at you
sitting across from somebody so it's
pointing in two directions or
omnidirectional when you want to record
every sound in the room so cool and I
haven't seen that anywhere but on the
Blue Yeti made by the same company that
has made high-end Studio mics that have
been used on lots and lots of big hit
records blue has been around for more
than 20 years and today blue is part of
Logitech for creators and we record this
podcast on Blu Sona XLR mic which is
also incredibly simple but it has an XLR
cord it's not a direct into your
computer USB we do it with the big boy
stuff the big boy cable so if you want
to up it and get even even more Prof
professional quality blue has you
covered with their blue Sona XLR we
record we made it weird Val and I have
them on the arms uh the extending arms
on our desk and we love them they sound
so fantastic so blue has evolved with
the show as we have grown as well sounds
fantastic and you can show your support
of the show by giving your next audio
project uh a try so go to bluemike.com
and use code weird for a special deal on
any blue microphone that's the blue Sona
that's the Blue Yeti whatever you see
there just use code weird at checkout
that's bluemike.com show your support of
the show and get that project up and
running let's do it get into it alright
everybody I really really hope you enjoy
Carrie she was so fun you're about to
see or listen to one of the most fun
conversations I've had definitely check
out reno911 on uh and in December on
Comedy Central and in the meantime enjoy
this chat with my new friend Carrie get
into it
oh they scream don't even worry about
the screen
go here we go
Elsa Anna
a month
what are you a vampire you have to be
invited you're alone you're a tall drink
of water I am
and long you well this couch is perfect
for you yeah I love it totally normal
yes say it say it I love a deep couch we
have a deep couch at home and I secretly
do love when my short friends come in
their little feet dangle do you know
Melissa Rouch by any chance Rouge pouch
I call her I know her but I don't know
yeah yeah and I mean she made those
jokes she had like a ventriloquist dummy
like dangling off the knee of the of the
Ventura the whole time but you look like
a normal human person thank you that's
the first time I've been called that
right
I mean I feel
and you can cross it and you can even
put your shoes on it don't worry oh the
things I can do on this couch that's
kind of a weird Community we haven't
even I mean we haven't even scratched
the surface of the things that I can do
on this couch thank you for the double
mic because it's gonna be loud what I'm
gonna do on this couch cheers I just did
a club this weekend yes
and they gave me a gift and it was the
it was a doctor what are we good I heard
cursing under your breasts
oh she's like relaxed
she's like is this how it's going to be
the whole time this is Katie a nice
first podcast I yell at her so well it's
obvious why no offense Katie but pull it
together very clear why Katie is this an
internship for Katie it's an unpaid 10
12-year internship she's been interning
what's happening I really could like
show business is so you could find
someone to be like produce my podcast
for free a hundred percent and pretend
for 10 years you'd be like you know as
soon as you quit there's like a long
line I feel like that's sort of like I
think a lot of people have that
situation I think this industry is built
on like well with the promise of yes
well that was ucb's dill pickle do you
remember UCB no no no no no I still
bring it up like it's current but they
got in trouble because they were not in
trouble but people were making uh a
right fuss yes
is this
the cockness monster
um
I'm supposed to do a movie last year and
they just assumed I could do an
Australian accent and I was like Rudolph
I just did an audition recently and the
character was from Pittsburgh and I just
said at the top I went I I can't I can't
yet do the accent like it would take me
many hours yeah and I'm not like I
didn't say this but I wanted to be like
I don't want to do that for the audition
I was like just look at my face right
see if I'm funny do you like is this
something like a true set could you
imagine repositioning the cameras for
this right and if you can then I'll
learn the Pittsburgh accent and I think
it was a mistake why that you didn't do
the accent was a mistake the idea in
Showbiz that like that people can
Overlook things or like use their
imaginations I always think I'm not
putting down anybody I auditioned for by
the way I just think that's never a safe
bet like right like you audition for
something and the crowd is bad like you
have to do a live audition don't worry
they can they know who's fun no they
don't no they don't they're [__] Ding
Dongs no they don't they're ding dong
monsters you are going to audition for a
doctor don't wear an iPad match
unless it's for scurvy I learned it the
hard way no you look at the heart no no
no I just thought it would not be a fun
fun thing for you to imagine tell me
about your early auditions
okay I can't wait and on my life
no on my life this happened okay I can't
wait I I have okay pause okay because I
just want to reposition the camera I
just want to read by the camera I just
want to feel how I feel right now
because I'm so excited yes like legit I
will not let you down I don't think you
will and how often in life are you like
this is gonna be it and I so don't rush
it okay okay I'll take my time okay do
you want a water no do you want a magic
mind productivity drink thank you okay
keep going
do you want some Advil
I just love that you're so excited
you're like let's see carpet yeah do you
want to recarp in the room somebody said
I should do rubber floors in here I was
like a Sex Dungeon
my friend Judah was like Robert floors
are really cool right now is he a serial
killer yeah he should not be allowed
listen to this voice and listen to his
carpet preference he's definitely can I
say real quick please I I wanted to like
Dexter and then when you're gonna say I
wanted to like my friends I don't like
we're breaking up Judah Judah Miller yes
oh you wanted to like Dexter but you
didn't can I tell you why because I want
to know your thoughts please I thought
he was going to go around like axing
people or like murdering them but as
soon as he had them strapped to a table
and being like welcome I was like [__]
you this is like it's like the worst
kind of serial killer the torture
dissecting whack job with the clean room
with the Saran Wrap I know
pre-med students maybe we're the
audience yes yeah who wrote The Supreme
med student I tried to to watch it too I
know I shouldn't say I try to watch it I
watched it you did watch it but I
couldn't tell you anything about it well
that's a modern Phenom yeah you just
guzzle it down it guzzled it down and
it's not that modern I mean this was a
while ago this show I mean I think since
The Sopranos we've been binging I still
don't balk when it's on a greatest shows
of all time list but at the same time
it's like I don't remember I love him
can I smoke you smoke your jokey right
now because it's your place okay I wanna
I wanna first of all acknowledge that
Kevin Spacey is a flawed person and okay
you know reckon for his mistakes we're
all yeah okay finally yeah please no no
no no no this is how this is what we
should be talking about please I think
it's time to say it
you knew when you did this podcast you
were gonna hear me weigh in Kevin Spacey
it was in the email yeah I said do you
want to do my podcast where I weigh in
on Kevin's birthday
pie in the face for that Spacey it's
time and no one better to talk about it
than you and he has that I think it's a
handsome crease here but if you hit him
with a pie in the face he'd be finding
pie in there sure he would while sure
take that space right take that I think
it's distinguished yeah men are so lucky
that you can have like just like a hand
print on your face and people are like
he looks rugged he looks like my dad
totally disgusting no she should not
come out of her house yes get this right
beast in a hole I'm not endorsing it I'm
doing an impression of these people okay
anyway so Kevin Spacey flawedness noted
yes can we put that here sure sure I was
in Vancouver they don't have HBO Max
couldn't watch White Lotus they didn't
have I wouldn't want you without my
watch anyway what are we what are you
kidding please what are you kidding
that's leaving be in the doghouse which
is probably this room this is yeah this
is a great couch for hanging out this is
this is where I would sleep if we were
on the Rocks yeah sad yeah no sad
there's not even a rubber floor to hose
down in the morning which you would need
sure because you're so sad but you're
you are I don't know if we're there yet
if we're gonna make Jack Jack off jokes
yes oh we're there
again it was in the email do you want to
hear me make rubber floor jack off joke
but it's not it's better than that it's
a guy who's so sad he can't he has to
just on the floor and then he hoses it
once a week well and you better come the
day out we're putting that in we're
putting that in our house right now I
thought you made a new episode oh it's
in the episode already we could copy
that moment and just paste it every 15
minutes yeah like why did she keep
bringing that up it's so weird she went
in like first 30 seconds she's talking
about jacking off on his around the
floor first of all jacking off is the
funniest way to say it it's like a
jacket oh like that is what is that Jack
uh I love word and phrase origin I love
it oh etymology
I never say it because it always ends up
as either edamame or entomology oh yeah
and what's entomology study of bugs
living trees trees bugs bugs bugs bugs
okay is it etymology Adam well now you
just you just see if someone hums the
theme to Superman you can't remember the
theme of Indiana Jones do you understand
etymology
etymology etymology just think of Ed
Harris going you want to know where that
word comes from which is Ed Harris I
think we're all thinking that
pause let's have a moment of silence
he's very much with us
um he's alive yeah yeah yeah Harris is
live yeah why can't we have a moment of
silence for people that are still alive
while they can not hear it because he's
going to be listening to this I see blue
um what was my point you were saying
wow edama you love jack off like where
things come from where things come from
yeah where are things yeah yeah yeah
there's one yeah
we don't ever talk about that Jack
hammering so jacking means this like
this well a jackhammer goes like this
sure and Jack and then maybe it might be
donkeys or like Jack Jack Jack Jack what
are they Jax what is the what is a
donkey is a jack and a jacket a Jack and
a Jenny a jackass that's what it is and
a Jenny ass but that would be jack off
and who's jacking off to jackass right
well
somebody somebody comes real hard
Knoxville these days squirting oh yeah
he's a he's an old babe yeah I think
we're back to face crease see this
Knoxville is one of those dudes where
you're like full circle I don't care I
know I'm not saying he's Haggard I'm
just saying like the older he's he's he
is he's aging very well I just played
his his uh lover get in the car what do
you mean we didn't there was no there
were no cameras nothing happened there
was no cameras it was a role play game
no it's a reboot I'm in a couple
episodes of reboot but he uh he is I
play his his uh his lovers a spoiler
alert guys
sure and we do have Lulu which does
bring me back to Canada and they don't
have Hulu so you know what I watched
okay yeah I watched House of Cards oh
this is a lot I know it's really good
look what are we doing are we separating
the the artist from the what are we
doing you know what I've been thinking
about this a lot yeah I hear Michael
Jackson constant I'm not even and try
we're just playing it we're playing
there is a level uh forget it too spicy
spicy it's too spicy maybe we'll Circle
back let's put a pan in it because no
one wants to talk about it I'm going to
keep pointing to my assistant who isn't
here offset we're going to put a picture
his name it's Johnny Knoxville that's
weird he was so taken with you playing
his lover that he was like can I follow
me married children me too but somehow
professionally he's like your intern
yeah babe old babe oh total old babe
yeah did you watch old man not yet opens
with him having to get up like five
times to pee and you're still like it's
a sexy guy struggling with his prostrate
right see how he said prostrate
prostrate I have prostrate cancer I only
have cancer when I lay down uh uh that's
a dark ref put it put it Johnny Mark
that let's mark that to edit it out um
okay
audition story which you were gonna love
I can't oh do you think for a second yes
this whole little cinnamon swirl wasn't
I wasn't going like what are we getting
back to no no I'm in line for Space
Mountain right now yes oh that didn't go
well for me the first time we love Space
Mountain I do love Space Mountain I
think roller coasters are harder for the
very tall
first of all Space Mountain the thrill
old Walt Disney all four foot nine Walt
Disney I'm sure smoking a cigarette
right three foot two eating a pastrami
sandwich being like I'm the average man
of three foot two imagine in the future
somebody might be four foot nine imagine
hmm and then he's eating with this
drawing oh no no no no no no problems he
designed it but it's like tracks are
going over your head I know and then I
get on and I'm like Walt Disney never
imagined that a man might be my size no
some free no they would have shot me on
site if I showed up in 1954. and you
right yeah a glass cage forget about it
would you like to see the Twitter the
tall the straw lady look at the Funny
Face that she could make make the money
faces we can see them look At All by the
way
glad you said funny faces yes
I did myself a favor and typed in your
character's Trudy dirty Weigel I wrote
Trudy Weigel yes best moments oh Jesus
Christ you're so funny I know you've
done a lot more but I was like I'm in
the mood for that flavor I was dying and
there's one talk about faces yes where
um the the main guy
the funniest part of that scene I mean
the whole thing's hilarious is when you
walk in and the camera's just on your
face and you don't even know what the
scene is and I'm dying at your face I
really am glad you brought that up
that's right I really wanted to
compliment that specific and it's not
that you you like it's not it's not code
to be like you're weird it you did
something a normal face but like kind of
like a smile and like your eyes are just
kind of they're they're not twitching
but there's well I was thank you dying
laughing and I was like I really think a
lot of
I don't know where I'm getting this but
I imagine that a lot of people think
it's easy to make a funny face you say
make a funny face
you'll make a small funny face that
actually makes you laugh out loud it's a
compliment to have another comedian say
that was a funny face because it's often
a No-No in our business to be making
pulling faces as silly says sure
mugging I mug though I love mug well not
in my action you know understand when I
do stand up there's no shame in Wheeling
yes whatever you want of course in
acting
harder and it's not it's frowned upon
and it's understandable
but I feel like the screens are getting
the screens are getting smaller yes
um I don't know that's not really true
the streets are getting no the screens
the screen when it's a movie and you're
pulling a face it's like oh wait a
minute but our teeth are right like I
watch on an iPad now I mean you know
remember iPad Mini what happened to that
know nobody wanted it nobody wanted that
no iPad mini is just the big iPhone
right but uh we're watching on little
airplanes we're watching watches so
you're right mugging might be coming
back the more things change the more
they stay the same two thing it's not
really a thing I tried to make an excuse
for it but but I will say I I do try in
in I uh I try to uh not do that in in
other things necessarily but Trudy that
that character that will do it she's a
Mugger which is a dream I feel like
we'll get into that we're gonna do the
audition story and you had another thing
you were gonna tell me about my heart
left like you were gonna have me
audition Space Mountain no no Space
Mountain and audition we're gonna do yes
uh so let's not get sidetracked and talk
about treaty we won't forget to talk
okay okay but what fun to play like a
hard funny character yes you know what I
mean yes like Michael Scott I watch
Michael Scott and I'm like oh that's
just someone who's allowed to be yes as
funny as they can be right you're always
hoping for a role like that right but
like you know you end up playing a more
real person yeah anyway okay let's do
Space Mountain and then we'll tell me
what we were saying okay we're going to
do Space Mountain now okay um so uh
space Sounds not interesting I wet
myself I was a child it was horrifying
horrible this is why you're begged my
father to take me this is death
it was awful it was not for me the in
the dark no not for me and so as an
adult even like my son went once he's
like not for me it's not for us so you
begged your dad who I'm imagining is
tall
sure my dad's a little taller than me
okay it's interesting you keep bringing
up the height thing I could have been
two foot two and I still would have wet
my I understand and I might have been I
was a child okay so you're a little baby
and you and you went pee pee they must
have a protocol for that though for sure
that's a hose that's a hose and they
have a code for it
somebody uh leaked
Uranus is code for poo poo on the ride
is it yeah I'm just kidding how do you
know this because you want to go into it
okay that was also in that scene with
this with the sunburn you're like let's
check if you have a little surprise for
me I called it something weird it was
like 20 years ago I know I know isn't
that weird you're like Oopsy Daisy you
have a turtle yeah a turtle turtle great
and then you realize let's let it finish
yeah like that it was like a half way
out God why
also when you drive off with the liver
on your car I I hadn't seen that one
these are all yes these are oldies and
maybe goodies they are goodies okay good
and I sure hope you know that I know
you've done beautiful stuff no no no so
you peed your was that super sad did you
go home afterwards I don't remember I
just remember it was horrif it was not
for me the ride was so scary do you
remember what point it was it was it
during the ride or was it Darkness like
what are we doing no see dark was huge
in in the 50s when they built that right
they were like okay imagine the dark and
everyone's whoa impossible and it ends
with a light oh you've done it again yes
exactly but that was like a basic have
you seen jackpotniks oh
you have to right after this you have to
watch jackpotnik did
does all these videos of himself he puts
himself in the old original Disney film
uh uh like uh interviews with Walt
Disney talking about building the park
no it's forget about it people retell
something is funny and it's like that
doesn't sound funny but no it already
sounds amazing a flavor and watch that I
will do myself I'll do myself three
flavors on Neapolitan all three three
times all three of them okay so your
audition okay your worst audition story
yes which was maybe my first uh
professional Edition we were at NYU and
I say we because the the same people
that I work with today yes all were
there together yes but with their Jewish
names no only one of them
just kidding that's my God
yeah we're looking huge one no all the
rest yeah
trillio that's he kept it right here by
the way Lo truglio said it forever and
then after we graduated he's like it's
Le trulio we were like is it because
that's new to us yes beat it the nicest
person on the planet no I know that's
the face of a sweetheart it's the
everything of a sweetheart it's the
everything of a sweetheart
whatever yeah whatever who cares who
cares he's a good guy
how dare you that's what I think
deadline's writing about yeah and she's
fired they're live right now outside the
window oh yeah I just saw a guy with
like a newsy cap and a cigarette and
he's like with a typewriter yeah
I find what a scoop to be one of the
funniest things what a school what a
scoop also what's that scoop
huh I mean I jack off we I don't know if
we got it
further away with scoop yeah but I think
it means someone's about to get it and
you scoop it and you get it sure that
could be yeah maybe that's not that
interesting it's not that fun it was
it's like finding out how you do a magic
trick it's like the bird was behind his
head yeah like you're like no no walking
around with a bird duct tape to it said
you don't want to know that you don't
want to know no I never believed that
the bird came out of the man's armpit be
amazed be amazed yeah yeah I agree okay
okay so actually that's a very good
intro to this really pathetic story I
don't like that word care but pathetic
story yeah really let's own that story
okay maybe okay you're getting a
vulnerable Story You're Gonna I'm gonna
change your mind right now okay I'm
bringing back the word BB TW it's coming
okay be prepared
my best friend in college Laura Shelson
was working she's a little bit older
than me so she was working in a uh at an
advertising agency now she's like one of
the heads of one of the big advertising
agencies edit that out and hopefully I
just had her promotion we don't correct
I have her card I was going to pass out
in case you need any advertising her
LinkedIn link any agencies
um she's like I have an audition for you
for like a commercial Like Money
commercial and this was the days when
big money oh life-changing money somehow
who knocked on us you know the actors
are making a lot of money on commercials
who stopped that why and where did it go
where did it go selling the money wasn't
coming in I'm guessing that it's like
big big celebrities are getting it
they're saving it all for that
like podcasting suffers the same thing
it's like some guy in New Hampshire used
to be able to start his podcast okay and
you know review films and now he's
competing with you know uh [__] oh I
had it on the tip of Jason Bateman homes
I thought you thought your name uh I
give it up that was Jason yes yeah keep
going so celebs are taking all the maybe
I don't know big cheddar but at the time
this was like oh my God I'm gonna
audition for a commercial and uh also
sort of felt by the way side note a
little bit like I don't know if I want
to do commercials like I'm an actress I
do theater so young now hilarious so you
were like hilarious rolling your own
drum cigarettes yeah I'm like I don't
know yeah would Steppenwolf do it right
exactly uh so I I but I you know I
lowered myself to to go to the audition
no I wanted it so bad of course it would
have been your year oh uh it would have
been my month my year How does it go
it's friends you're just playing along
have you ever seen my year it's 365 days
my dear have you ever seen my week this
is a different show I've never seen
seven of them you freak okay write that
down
right the idea for sitcom put it on
Spotify
it makes six cents a year okay okay so
that's what got you I
go into this audition and this is my
first time ever auditioning for a
commercial and I don't know if this is
still how they do it but the audition
the commercials they're called spots and
they have titles right but the title
doesn't often uh completely correlate so
this particular title
said mime
so imagine my delight
because I was taking mime at New York
University oh NYU mime school no
actually and when I went to school of
the arts I was an experimental theater
major but one of my elective classes was
mime so I thought you know I'm a college
I'm like you know so you're soaking up
full of myself I'm soaking it all up and
I'm like mime I got this like I'm gonna
pull out the my moves like you've never
seen yeah
not just pulling a rope
I'm pull okay so I go in I'm stretching
in the bathroom because this is really
going to be something
and I am
um
in this description it says mime and
then it says there's a voice over and
I'm simply reacting
to the voiceover I don't speak what is
the product
phone of Verizon some some phone service
okay
mimes have no need for that I guess I
could text right well they couldn't
because this is a pretext
landline this is landline days you only
needs a phone to kill another mime
that's right yeah uh you ever beat
someone on the phone
[Music]
it's a great Implement Let's Get Down
two-edged so you can yeah so I am
pulling out all of the mime yeah that I
that I have learned in my two months of
deep mime Deep dive I'm pulling ropes
I am catching birds I am stuck in a box
I'm stuck in a box with a bird I'm
pulling a rope I'm pulling a box oh
there's wind this way there's wind this
way there's wind from above wind in the
box where the road the Box there's wind
taking the bird yeah oh the thing you
wouldn't believe
um
and I finish this tour de force
performance and I'm wow they're doing
the voiceover they're reading it they're
reading the voiceover
and I'm sweating I'm giving it my all
because even if I you know if they don't
pick me at least I want them to say like
wow that was really something like are
there awards for just auditions because
I was sure I was going to get
shoes
the weird girl who did 45 minutes of
mine
or the best mime you've ever seen oh
yeah and here to deliver her non-speech
yes so I think
and I look up
and I swear to God I have never seen
more
confusion
Panic like I felt like I saw some like
fear horror horror and just silence
even my friend who's in the in the back
they were there she was there and she's
like this like can I rewrite this memory
in your mind and she has a cigarette and
yes almost all the way and that's loud
that cuts to her and the ash Falls so
she's just yeah and you hear it because
it's so quiet the ash
and you're like and then should I be
able to hear Ash right now she has a
little dog and the dog goes
perfect perfect I'll even pitch monocle
falls off into teacup into teacup yes
cool cool
the official sound of a upper class
person who's offended yes
[Music]
yes onto a fainting couch that's what
they're there for sure Shea's Lounge
all of those things happened
cool
and I was
like okay and is there anything else
that you want to see or no that's we're
great thank you so okay keep going I
have so many questions but I want to
hear what you're doing so did I yeah
because I just gave you what more could
you want yeah
I go home you gave them a Tour de France
sure sure
my girlfriend without all the bikes and
stuff yeah my girl I was going to
Victoria
to France which is a thing so it doesn't
work I was like you're a real tour to
France and you're like leave the bikes
you want to check that riff for double
meanings no I'll just say Tour de France
I actually thought it was a super riff
that you knew it was tour to four so
then you took it once you were doing a
bit on a bit
now mimes French tour de force Tour de
France yeah and and then I went there
was a red light that went off in my riff
computer this means something else and I
went just say it anyway more Jazz more
jazz or Jazz well it's actually it's a
deep trust I was like even if I say
something that doesn't make sense we'll
get it I'll pick it up curve big insult
so uh I got home and my girlfriend calls
me and and I'm like how did it go and
she's like Carrie what happened
and I was like what do you mean and she
said um I just have to say like that was
the funniest
thing that's like we were dying
and I said what do you mean what why
what she said you oh you weren't trying
to be funny I said no she said we were
just stunned
at your choice
and I said what do you mean
and I said it said mime and she's like I
know but you weren't supposed to
literally be a mime you just were
supposed to react like my reaction like
not talking like a wordless reaction
so I see this thing on TV
like months later and literally this is
the performance by the person who got
the part I'm ready so you do the
voiceover yeah not cell phones just
Verizon home phone right Verizon home
phone can Now cover two lines per your
house here that means you can have a
business line and a person online you
are making the smallest for just the
audio people the smallest
subdued nod with a smile just like a hmm
that is hilarious I can't believe it's
in for nod and smile no you don't it's a
waste of you it's a waste of you let it
do mine I call you it let it do mine
watch it go look at it go I look at all
the things it can do
if you could do all those things you
could definitely not and smile I I won't
tell the story because people have heard
the story a million times on this
podcast but I had an audition there were
no words it was for one of those
Domino's Pizza or Papa Gino's or
something like that where you serve Papa
Gino's at a restaurant and you don't
tell them and then they eat and they
like like a wait it's like a uh like
it's a prank oh real and it really is or
I believe they do it for real okay uh
yeah they do it for real you can always
tell when it's not real I feel like yeah
I'd wager my true my reputation as a
journalist obviously it feels real
because people
you say this is [__] propaganda
hey get over here you [__] well you
know what it was kachava who used to
sponsor this podcast I still like a
travel they have this ad on YouTube and
it was so fake everybody was like
kachava is a part of my morning it makes
me feel fantastic yeah and give me all
the nutrition I need and and just
because it's like an old guy that kind
of looks like he wouldn't be on TV but
he's still acting he's still like all
those nutrients in one place that's
super food supertastic and I'm just like
right nobody talks this way why not just
get because I guess most people don't
care if they fall for it feels like a
commercial yeah they fall yeah you know
why why because you want to believe sure
I'm not talking about good job I'm
saying like when you're watching a
commercial
even though you have your defenses up on
TV any story it's true you want to
believe yeah but I I was on a plane to
yesterday and I could see an ad for like
a groomer like something that'll cut
yours and your your hair and your nose
hair and stuff but you can get that at
the airport no it was on the TV of the
guy oh oh okay it was like they're
shining shoes and doing nose hair
trimming at the airport
I don't want to embarrass you but might
not offer you and my my service chair
Brazilian ma'am do you need a Brazilian
Indian nutty
man
um anyway I went from going like that's
stupid immediately being like I have to
get that like it's not an issue yet but
it will be yeah and I'm like I should
get this one yeah but it's for the
pleasure of believing that there's hope
do you know what I mean right like you
want Hope Oh but I do it I'm such a
sucker I do it on all you buy all sorts
of crap well and not necessarily buy it
but I'm I'm especially a sucker for the
medicinal ones and they'll say like not
a real person this is an actor but I'm
like maybe I have that remember they
need to get that there was that guy this
is this guy was so ahead of the curve
remember you'd see it on infomercials
but he made the infomercial look like
Larry King live no but it wasn't Larry
King it was someone else it actually
made it look like um
sorry this is I have to do this every
time
Spirits yeah I have the contract memory
Charlie Rose also Scandal noted okay he
was scandalized but you know all black
right
it looks like it looks really important
PBS yes someone on PBS is talking shut
up yes everybody shut up shut up is that
a British accent this must be real or is
it Cockney [__] and shine
all right
come round up into call Nation
you can all do
perfect Logan let's get home Lane don't
wear it to an audition for a doctor it's
a big leg I bet both both depends on the
doctor though if you're like a pirate
doctor that's what I'm saying scurvy
yeah that riff was
30 minutes
I think they're on the way out you know
why because I think even my dad is
getting like the memo has got no the
memo has gotten to him that like if you
talk about limes and scurvy that's like
I I file it under the same category as
pointing out that Frankenstein is
actually Dr Frankenstein's monster like
there's certain Corrections or
observations that at one time were
interesting and novel and they're not
anymore you're you're is also one of
them like the internet already did that
like yeah I know anyone is still doing
your just leave them be let it be
because it's not it's not that they
don't they've been corrected they do
they're just you're too dumb like yeah
it's not even dumb it's just like that's
not their strong suit yeah and that's
fine similarly the the the the the
titillation of improvising if scurvy do
you have any limes or or like we're in
an improv scene yeah and I eat the lime
and you go what do you have scurvy that
in 1999 that was
I love the for some reason one of my
go-to bits is always
uh some sort of sexually transmitted
disease that doesn't kill you herps
right I can't come I have herpes can't
come I have herpes is a great life can't
come I've got the clap uh I think it's
still happening although I'm gonna say
something okay I don't know what the
clap is I don't know either that's why
it's funny to me agree shingles I think
oh no terrible disease we don't want
this that might have been something I
would have laughed about but now that
I've gotten older and the doctor says
you need a shingles vaccination I'm like
oh that's not so funny anymore yeah
that's what Steve Martin says facts he
goes meaning I made a prostrate cancer
he's like you make all those jokes when
you're young and then when you're older
and everyone you know starts dying
you're like you you walk around like
good afternoon
he did become very polite nothing funny
about mortality
very very good like you were the
funniest comedian now you're like very
good good day everyone it's good to have
four square meals a day I don't know
what it's at four because I pictured a
square that should be three triangle
meals a day yeah the meals themselves
are square or Square they're squared the
meals are square meals are square what's
the etymology of that I don't know this
isn't Square we have so many things to
ask and also later if
Jeeves is dead
you make all those search engine jokes
when you're young and then when all your
search engines start dying you stop
making those jumps those jokes Jeeves
went out with scurvy Jesus and the web
crawler spider are both dead
you know how they died they jumped off
Alta Vista oh no
oh no Google
nothing I worked at another one it
didn't work none of them worked no but
that would be a fun you know how Google
cements changes their like screen their
little thing yeah that'd be a good one
or two Skies
hanging from the L he's like nobody
wanted to ask me well now it's asks..com
what is it ask.com they got rid of
Jeeves yeah also I'm gonna throw away no
I know Jesus yeah Jeeves is gone you
know who else is gone yeah there used to
be three cinnamon toast crunch guys
now she's Wendell
really and I can't believe you know that
I know a little bit about my serial
characters
tell me why did you do it you didn't do
it did you didn't check my Wiki I did
check your Wiki and you don't see you
didn't see anything in there about
cereal I'm sorry did I have to read the
references
if I if I fine-tooth combed the
reference
is this this really you love this is
real no tell me what
do you know who my father is I'm
building this up like it's gonna is this
real this is real put on the no riff hat
put on the no riff the Riff hat is on is
your dad the Cocoa Puffs bird
your dad is cuckoo for Cocoa and he's
count chocula your dad yeah my dad who
took you on a ride who took me on all
the rides that he's of average height
ish there's so many wonderful things
about my dad aside from the fact he's
Sunny you also could have said he's
Sunny well I don't know my father my
father is this guy okay my dad is sunny
I know his name is sunny okay like
Toucan Sam yes not the Pelican from
fruit yes you mean two kids call The Man
by his name his name is
my friend
his name is my friend
we pan over he's in the at the table
with his lawyer crying like what was he
accused of
and cuckoo for anything
okay so your dad was the voice of Sonny
yeah it is still is still yeah so he
doesn't like smoke cigars or anything he
did forever your dad did my dad smoked
cigars then he smoked pipes no no I was
gonna say because that would now said he
would be like um
I think we need to recast he was uh from
a very young age he did uh radio and he
had his mom found cigarettes in his
shirt pocket one time and she's like
what are these and he said I need these
for my voice she's like okay well don't
smoke too many of them that was an old
belief yeah well he didn't he knew that
wasn't true but I just fell for it I
think the excuse would still work on me
like I got you I do know some voice over
people I think it's baloney pajoni but
they're like it it helps have a well
listen to Will Arnett he has a beautiful
voice I think so well he used to be
anyway yeah he's a great voice I miss my
cigarette voice I do I watch back old
shows and I'm picturing it I'm applying
cigarette filter to listening to you
right now I miss it uh not uh
starting Reno like a little bit in there
but mostly before like were you smoking
when you did Reno
um
maybe right at the beginning okay yeah
Tom Lennon smoker oh we were Tom and I
were heavy smokers Tomlin in that smoker
face Tomlin and you know Matt when we
were 16. what's my smoke yeah
shoot Dave's about a smoker eyes I saw
him on SNL I was like you can tell by
his eyes are they yellow they're not
yellow they're not baggy there's just
something about them that I go like I
don't know why maybe it's because I know
he smokes what is it he's happy
and fulfilled and relaxed is your mom
Philip Morris like how many oh God I
miss it I miss it it's terrible we
shouldn't do it
a doctor with an eye patch comes in and
goes like yeah
I am but oh you were never a smoker no
but I did I I used to chew nicotine gum
I'm the only person that I know that
never smoked what did chew nicotine gum
because it's fantastic and I still have
friends but it's also addictive and
that's why I won't go into it fantastic
just I just said this on the Curt Brown
on all episodes so I'm not going to say
it every episode but it's like but what
addiction is doing is it's growing
new receptors in the brain so it's like
killing other things and and replacing
it with like a nicotine receptor
flavor country
[Music]
cowboy hat my
is marked outside parked outside under
the Time Square California
remember that there was a time when
cigarettes ruled the world so much the
Times Square was the marble Cowboy I do
blowing smoke rings speaking of how
amazing my dad is my 16th birthday we
stepped out of uh the theater seeing
House of Blue leaves and it was Susie
Kurtz and uh my dad had the ticker tape
thingy it said happy
16th birthday care sweet 16. yes I have
a picture of it I have a phone did you
time it so it would come when you were
walking out there it just went over and
over it's going there and then it's up
above there's like a there was a big
light sign and it said that well and
then you pan down because I'm assuming
this is in the 80s uh 80s 80 yeah I was
born in 1970. so you're going down and
it's just like a horrible peep show Good
Girls Girls Girls Girls Girls clams
fried clams frogs
fries and boobs so sorry what does that
mean fried rice what is that is anyone
being breaded in there at the boot do
they come together
is it a basket or a buffer is it a
basket nobody wants to see that wet
paper underneath the fried clam basket
the reminder of how much grease you just
say I just made me hungry talking about
Howard Johnson's fried clams I grew up
in Connecticut and New York City I was
going to say East Coast we love a fried
clam yeah sort of like a piece of rubber
oh yeah in the best way it's like a
piece of rubber you found in the sea
hiding in a shell yeah with a little
tartar sauce and then you deep fry it
yeah
sure well I'm doing something from
Boston here yeah that's where I'm from
are you yeah but well and then I
remember the the age I was that I was
like got grossed out by them and that
and now I'm back I'll eat a [__] yeah
I'll eat it just when I'm at home sure
just when you're home not when you're
out cigarette in the sea
I don't know if you were making fried
clams in your house you better be the
[__] Gordon's fish even better like
do people ever make fried clams like
they're like let me get let me just
Chuck
a clam yeah you shook it yeah
just like you you shot clams you got
corn corn
it just means to remove from its
encasing so every night when I shower
yeah
let me show you baby let me check this
shirt those pants off when you peed
yourself by the way I'm still sad about
at Space Mountain you got home and you
chucked your clothes off it's a project
your wet clothes it's okay it's okay I
changed my pants since then
I did I do what I don't like about it is
that I'm afraid that that like how old
were you
no no way of telling no way of knowing
probably well seven eight seven see
that's the age yeah that's the age that
they say psychologically they say around
seven I I well you also are tall so like
I probably was too young to be going on
a ride like that but I was tall right so
I was able to get on same in fact I was
able to go on those things before maybe
I yes ought to us
let's bring this up an octave this whole
podcast let's bring let's bring this
let's bring let's bring this up an
octave I listen to your band it's really
good at first I thought maybe started a
comedy band and I was like well some
comedy the reason you probably think
that is because we did start it really
was kind of a joke that we were starting
something because we were all had other
careers but our boyfriends were all in
bands and so we said while they were all
on tour kind of as a joke let's go into
the practice space and write a song and
when they get home we'll be like wear a
band too but as we were about five
minutes into it we were like oh wait we
actually are a band and you like it and
we love it and we started playing like
two
I would say two weeks of playing every
day and a guy poked his head in and said
hey
I don't did you live in New York ever
yeah okay so we were in the in East
Village like on Avenue A but this is
like the night early 90s like this is
not the nicest technically Alphabet City
but yeah what city
what city
you're right you're right it was around
I wanted to show New York knowledge but
it was so nasty then that that's why
like it was a terrible area it was a
terrible area y'all should have bought
it back then no [__] how it's so close
it's touching a great area a great
Christian area is touching a great area
go ahead and buy the shoes you know what
there were no greater
Johnson Square Park was shut down
because it was so dangerous yeah I lived
on it yeah yeah exactly terrible
so I we were playing we played in there
for a couple of weeks
and he said hey I have this we're doing
a party in Brooklyn next week do you
guys want to play and we were like we're
like we're not a band and he said well
it sounds like you're a band and we said
we have three songs he's like great come
play three songs
so we went and played three songs
and at that party this is great John
Zorn who's an amazing Jazz Trumpeter
said
I am working with this label off of it's
called Avant records in Japan would you
guys be interested in making an album so
we said we only have three songs he goes
you'll write some more yeah so we wrote
some more and we went in and we uh you
wrote some filler wrote some filler uh
we recorded it it came out and it got
three and a half stars in Rolling Stone
magazine and the whole Center of Spin
Magazine and I got my name on the cover
like Rolling Stone like it was the it
was the weirdest sort of like what's
happening Fast Track
Disney World back up but you were on the
fast track to to show this sort of low
bottom of the riot girl world music I
feel like is one of the most difficult
here's what I'll say about music and
then I want to hear your thoughts I mean
I'm not saying shut up while I talk I'm
just saying this is a theory I want to
hear your thoughts yes meaning the only
reason I'm saying it is for your
thoughts you can find and understand
covered person on Spotify
and you're like this is as good as
anything right like that's not most art
isn't like that right like you go to
even a stand-up Open Mic probably
everybody's gonna be pretty true that's
true there's stuff on Spotify where
you're like or Tick Tock people hat yeah
totally agree you hear a voice on
YouTube Tick Tock and you're just like
the difference between this person and
Billy eilish I'm not putting down Billie
eilish in fact she's kind of an anomaly
with her brother in the songwriting and
everything but I'm just saying like
voice Talent all that sort of stuff
you're like seems to be marketing
question mark or like some sort of angle
The Big Break The Big Break yeah they
didn't get a break what is it what is it
indeed I know indeed I'll show I'll show
my husband these things all the time on
tick tock on Tick Tock I'm just a lurker
like I love to just look at yeah you
know and I'll show him that's how I am
on Ashley Madison
ha -ha-hate
wait is that still a thing I don't think
it is because there was a breach yes
remember somebody hacked it it was all
the names all the Dirty Boys the shop
for the ladies but never buy that's such
a stupid idea we're like uber for
Affairs yes like no [__] up your life
yes and pay for it go to go be a skis a
while don't bring HTML into your
cheating I know no don't have a password
I love it and then I love that it was
like exposed you love dirty these
cigarettes and Ashley again let's be
real Alphabet City right you were living
in the in the Rough and Tumble GG Allen
New York right yes yeah that's where he
died I think that's why I know that for
sure yeah oh back in the day my you know
when I was little my dad was living in
the West Village and it was like the 70s
and 80s in New York that was a different
time that was a different time he didn't
go around saying I'm Sunny the cuckoo
part like he was like how are you doing
back then you couldn't you couldn't just
walk around and be a cartoon bird you
had to keep it hidden let's talk we
didn't really talk enough about that yes
did you love that your dad was [__]
Sunny yes did he ever in Earnest go like
sweetheart I gotta be honest I'm not
cuckoo for these great well I feel like
my might have been my half-brother
somebody or my half sister Somebody went
to school and said and the teacher had
to call and say you're we did a career
day at school and your your child thinks
you're a cartoon bird and my dad was
like I am a cartoon bird and like three
doctors or straight jackets like slowly
back out of the room oh oh oh oh oh okay
okay okay good okay release the child
release the child let's talk everything
cocoa Buffs we're just gonna do our
mid-roll ads and then we'll be right
back okay mineral ads
pardon the interruption weirdos this
episode is brought To Us by our friends
at next Evo here they are I'm holding
them right here and if you watch the
intro you know I am traveling currently
I am in Vancouver and that's how much I
love my next Evo specifically these
stress CBD complex these are made with
hemp extract and ashwagandha which is an
adaptogen that helps your body cope with
stress so two things this is like a
serious serious serious secret weapon uh
in my stress Arsenal I don't think I've
used my own promo code as much on a
product ever before in my life Val and I
both absolutely swear by these so give
yourself The Ultimate Gift of a
stress-free holiday with next Evo
Naturals fast absorbing CBD products so
you guys know that we've we've had other
CBD brands on in the past I've cleared
my shelf for real for real and replaced
all of it with next Evo why because next
Evo's stress CBD complex gummies are
clinically proven to have four times 4X
better absorption than standard CBD they
got science involved and guys they
cracked it you take one of these and you
feel it fast it's not like so many
tinctures that I've taken we're not sure
if you are even seeing any results this
gift gets you where you're gonna feel it
right away no other CBD brand can
promise that and I absolutely absolutely
love these gummies and I swear by them
next Evo's smart sorb I love that smart
sword technology is how they do it they
deliver CBD to your system in as little
as 10 minutes unlike other CBD Brands uh
regular CBD CBD oil Works more slowly
because of how our bodies processed
oil-based ingredients compared to water
soluble supplements and regular CBD only
achieves two to ten percent absorption
two to ten so that's over ninety percent
of what you think you're getting is
going to waste but smart sword upgrade
cbd's natural absorption power it's
scientifically formulated to deliver
more CBD fast the only brand
clinically proven to deliver 30 times
better absorption in the first 30
minutes fight holiday stress with next
Evo natural stress CBD complex gummies
featuring ashwagandha clinically proven
to reduce stress by 70 percent I
personally can attest to that Val can
attest to that ashwagandha and CBD are a
dream team that work together to Target
the source of rising stress hormones
like cortisol and next Evo is the only
brand that combines a patented natural
whole plant ashwagandha that's eight
times more powerful than regular
ashwagandha and they're a hundred
percent U.S hemp derived U.S hemp Drive
smart swarm CBD with four times better
absorption than standard CBD so not only
is it better CBD it's better ashwagandha
and you can feel it I take these on
planes I take these before uh phone
calls with my with my folks I mean
they're and sometimes honestly it's not
like it uh sends you to another planet
it's a very functional and here on Earth
kind of Place meaning I take these when
I when I'm working when I'm writing
whenever I just want to ease and flow in
uh flow with whatever I'm trying to do
it's such a wonderful thing and I'm so
glad they're here to sponsor the podcast
so get smarter CBD with next Evo
Naturals and get up to 25 off
subscription orders of 40 or more at
next evo.com
podcast and use promo code weird that's
n-e-x-t-e-v-o.com slash podcast and then
use promo code weird
uh next up the second Pete's pick do you
think your job stinks do you think your
job stinks well just wait until you hear
what it's like to be a funeral clown I
guess that's a real thing funeral clown
long before all of human knowledge was
in your pocket people had some pretty
bizarre professions luckily you don't
have to be a sin eater and you don't
have to go see a barber surgeon now but
you will find out what it's like to get
surgery with a shave Wondries new
podcast this job is history is hosted by
our friend Chris Parnell from SNL and
Rick and Morty nobody funnier and better
to listen to than Chris Parnell and this
podcast is steeped in factual history
this brilliantly funny podcast delves
into quirky and absurd jobs from the
past with hilarious interviews that are
infused with fascinating true Easter
eggs so come get weird with with them
every week as improv comedians from
Groundlings and UCB act out their
old-fashioned gig from their time you'll
be glad your guidance counselor didn't
recommend any of these jobs and who's
funnier than Chris Parnell and who are
funnier than the improvisers at
Groundlings and UCB and what's a funnier
topic than weird weird job jobs from
history I mean funeral clown
I want to hear the funeral clown episode
it's hard to say funeral clown no one's
funnier than Chris Parnell check out
this job is history clock in and follow
this job as history on Amazon music
Apple podcast or listen early and AD
free by joining wondry Plus in the
onedry app all right everybody let's get
back to Carrie
Cocoa Puffs we're back
we're back oh tell me I just want to
know everything so you start there you
did think it was cool you talked about
it at school they were worried that it
wasn't real that wasn't me it was my it
was my half brother might oh yeah yeah
um somebody somebody did or maybe I made
up that story because it's so great but
but uh no we don't have any fact
Checkers here no oh this is a fact check
freeze out but but I I uh oh always and
my dad was doing
um he was uh don imus's sidekick
character voice guy oh really yeah so he
was like a multi-fest oh boy he still is
he's he's yeah he Skittles Taste the
Rainbow Guy now he's that guy barking at
me to taste it yeah yeah
that's huge I know and he was Lionel
Lord of The Thundercats which is the
which was like wait Lionel lion O Lord
of The Thundercats did you ever watch
the ThunderCats the main guy yeah so do
you know that he was the main guy in
[__] Thundercats yes I told you this
too under thunder Thundercats hoe which
I don't find appropriate
I it's thunder thunder Thundercats sex
worker
nasty nasty hoe I told that to
um Dave krumholtz we were working on
um something together
and we were just talking I don't know
how and it came or he he I think he said
thundercat's underground toe or
something I said you know that's my dad
literally tears came to he's like what
I'm dead he's dead he goes for my
Jennifer he's like that killed him real
killed him yeah there's uh there's got
to be super fans I remember being a kid
and being like I really want to get into
this I think it was just when it aired
or something like I couldn't quite get
my get enough of it right because I did
love it yeah I mean there's cats with
swords yeah weren't they men that turned
into cancer were they always cats they
were always kept I don't remember I
remember that one I don't remember the
origin story you know what you have to
do look up you know Jihad you know Jihad
to do you know what Jihad I try and slip
it in it's weird it's like you're weird
it's like a weird it's like the only
Tourette's thing that I have Jihad
um uh look up I'm giving you lots of
homework look up they there's an
outtakes video of them recording you
know just the filthiest mouths you know
they're all like of course smoking
cigars and drinking and you know oh fun
oh it's so filthy and this guy kind of
looked like he had that disease where
patches of your skin go white it did
look like that didn't it you kind of
looked like he had that yeah I don't
know what that's called but I love that
you yes and I almost said entomology
again Jesus Christ no it's called Uh
hit it go ahead you can hit me it's
called what if I just punched you so
hard because it's called Uh impetigo
thank you and the tiger and the tiger he
was a number tiger probably how it
started yeah it was before Thundercats
know what he had it
so was your mom around yes what is she
doing my mom was amazing but she was not
in the entertainment business at all she
was a laugher oh my God she was a
laugher she passed away five years ago
much too young yeah she was she was
incredible yeah best combo it is the
best combo but my dad's also a big
laugher like he loves to laugh he loves
to give the floor
he loves to you know be PR he's so proud
always to you oh
and they love you literally I could like
poop in a cup and my dad would be like
my daughter cup are you the only no you
already my dad my dad remarried and had
my brother and my sister okay and
they're incredible too they've worse
well what when did yesterday
he's like and then he was out I'm not
cuckoo for this I think he was out
that I think Cocoa Puffs was while they
were married but then he was like I'm
too cuckoo this is too cool it's like
I'm out of here I love cuckoo and this
is too cuckoo near a hoe yeah
was there infidelity I don't know it's
not important the importance thing how
old were you I think I was eight see
it's run your pee peeing in your pants
we're making connections wow yeah
it was a it was a wet thigh for help oh
my God you didn't
foreign
[Music]
it's like equal parts terrible and also
just right
that should be on a banner for your next
year it's terrible yes it's a quote and
you look at the fine print and it's like
it's him yeah yeah he said it about
himself and he put and he's the one
putting the banner up that's so weird is
that hit get down you're gonna hurt
yourself
so they got divorced when you were
forgive me but right around the age
where you're old enough to kind of
understand it was it difficult forgive
you because you're telling me this for
the first time forgive me for bringing
it up I mean I could be like let's talk
more about cinnamon I thought you were
like I hate to tell you this but your
parents broke up but you were old enough
to get it oh I got it it was a gut but
I'm younger maybe it's all I remember
the day I remember yeah but you know you
have to do what you have to do they had
to do what they had to do of course but
you did take it hard yes I did how did
you process it
um
heroine no no there's no like great big
story it was just hard I don't know I
guess that's what I'm driving at is I'm
interested in like there was conflict in
my family everybody knows that like it
was just like they just didn't really
get along yeah and then let's just say
let's just say that let's just leave it
when you say that it's like it was much
worse oh no right let's just say it was
a rocky road
I was World War Three
um I don't want to put anything on it
but but that is when I got really into
performing and it wasn't any sort of
correlation or am I oh I'm sure yeah I'm
sure there's a you know also like why is
she a clown yeah
do this what was the first thing that
you found that you was like an outlet I
mean clearly you're so naturally funny
comedy no doubt it's such a boring story
tell me what do you mean I feel like
it's Universal to I mean I feel like
it's every I feel like it's every
comedian podcast
yes for me uh you know I didn't I was
very shy as a little kid and I think my
mom was like is she gonna talk at some
point or
um yeah and then I felt like one time I
remember being in a classroom
and I remember
a teacher writing a substitute teacher
writing her name Miss Mills on the
on the chalkboard and I remember
something
happened and I
stood up as if being possessed and I
crossed out the m and I put a p
and that was like my big missed pills
and I sat back down and the class loved
it and I thought like oh this feels
really good like I just appeared in the
room for the first time
and I was like okay so I am not the
pretty girl I'm not the
um I'm not
sporty yeah I'm not which Spice are you
I know I am silly I'm not Posh I'm
definitely not Posh
silly did you say cocky I said
you're not from cochinshire I mean it's
called baseball
I think Christian Bale has got me have
you ever heard him talking when I was
playing Batman yeah what is Batman now
for me bro I'm like that can't be we
gotta work on that I'm just kidding
Christian Bale please do the podcast
um go uh so you got the you know what I
love about that bit it existed like a
lesser would have just went
more like miss pills not as good not as
good you wrote it which also I would say
sort of is the joke like the joke is
that you were so motivated to like erase
where is she going what is she yes
and we all know what it looks like when
you write on new lyrics
it's funnier than a dry erase
yes and the acknowledgment and then the
victory walked back to the desk the sit
down then the reveal as she comes into
the room yeah she sees second laugh best
bitter that's the best it's all been all
my comedy career has been downhill since
miss pills you can't talk miss pills
that's your my name is
I I love everything about it can I also
add yes and your big laugh your back is
to the audience
that never happens it's this like weird
it's like walking away from a car as it
explodes you did that so brave you were
sitting and you didn't even get to see
but you felt it like I like to think it
blew your hair forward a little bit just
The Bravery just The Bravery of it you
know I mean I don't like to call myself
a hero but where's miss pills
dead she killed herself that day
drama yeah that it was horrible to see
no that actually made me feel great
because that was a justification and my
bit really made it so funny that she
ended it yeah yeah okay so then NYU the
states news who cares who cares tell me
about the best nap you've ever taken
there's a question you don't get on
podcasts I love napping me too but have
you ever had one where you like I can't
believe I got away with that or it
nailed you like you fell asleep in a
weird place I can sleep anywhere I think
it was from honestly being on tour with
the band where you just have to be able
to sleep wait so you and Kate like cake
like went on tour okay so yeah go back
to them yeah so you you rocket past
Jimmy Kimmel was like do you realize how
many people hate you right now and he
turns the band and the band's like but
and our boyfriends had come back from
being on tour and they were just like
what like what is happening what band is
your boyfriend live uh I was in a had a
couple of boyfriends in a band called
shutter to think they're amazing Craig
wedron okay um and then
um girls against boys
um but uh we were playing a show at the
Knitting Factory in New York yes and
afterwards we were backstage and
somebody said Rico classic is is here to
see you and we were like I don't think
he's here to see us but okay send him
back
so he came back and he said I'm I'm a
fan I bought your record because I liked
the artwork and I'd like to do a single
with you
tomorrow when you have your next show
could I get some friends on the guest
list we said sure So the next night
we're playing
and in comes ricocastic who's 30 feet
tall with uh
Neil Young
and an email
he comes backstage that night and says I
have a new label called Vapor records
off of Warner Brothers and I would love
for you to be my second band we have
Jonathan Richmond yeah Neil Young wow so
we did a single with Rico classic and
Neil put it out and then we did two more
albums with Neil for Vapor records and
we toured with him
in Europe and and in America whoa yeah
what is your partner who was in a more
traditional band trajectory produced us
he produced loved us yeah yeah Craig
wedran and Craig weather does the music
for the for the uh for he did the music
for the state for Reno he's married to
Tom Lennon's sister oh so it didn't work
out yes
no it's going well yeah it's going well
with someone no no no you know when
you're younger and you're dating people
you're like are you the one or is it
your you you know what's weird you were
dating someone else's husband I know you
know what I mean weird way to look at it
yeah and and you're kind of going like
is this my husband yeah and then when
you break up really you're saying you're
someone else's husband yeah you're not
mine I put him back on the Shelf yeah
and he put me back on and then somebody
comes back and picks it it's like when
you put a jar of pickles in the cereal
aisle all right and then that's
sometimes how you find them yeah
somebody else's pickles yeah my guide to
dating
somebody else's pickles
orney Adams a very funny comedian had a
great bit about how he hadn't met his
wife yet which means she's out there
dating which means someone is out there
[__] his wife that's phenomenal isn't
that great when I saw that but I was
like it was right there it's true it's
like until you meet your partner they're
out having sex with somebody else
yes what are you doing and if she wasn't
a real [__] Like is she this is why you
should save yourself to her man yeah
yeah from JK 100 JK do it
do it a ton just do it kids do it just
do it a ton don't get the clap or scurvy
or shingles or shingles or shingles or
shingles prostate cancer so then you
what was Neil Young like did he smell of
cinnamon he's Horrible no
um
he's how you would dream he would be
yeah they were playing one summer they
were doing we were doing festivals and
crazy he was there with Crazy Horse
and our uh Elliot Roberts who passed
away a couple years ago who's a God who
was
Neil's manager and Crazy Horse I think
and Joni Mitchell and you know actual
people not I don't know I don't know
what they were doing with us I I think I
feel like they just like love new modern
hip stuff and they're like hey this is
fun yeah it's flattering but we don't
put ourselves in that World by any
stretch of the imagination sure so uh
but we would you were after after shows
you know we would be like
hungry at these festivals and Elliot
would say you know go and kneel they go
in their dressing room they've got like
lobster no one's eating and we would go
in and Crazy Horse and Neil would just
be yelling at each other every night
with love like brothers like you know
you play that riff wrong or whatever you
jumped into Sue what is this and we just
like tiptoe in and they were just like
uncles they're like girls girls get the
lobster get the get the fruit fruit you
know by the way yes not even by the way
I just love every part of that I love a
music argument it's supposed to be in
four four you played in three but it
just was like and it never felt scary
like oh grown-ups it felt like brothers
and like uh adrenaline and and passion
and they cared and they cared and my
first writing job was uh for a show
called is that true no my second writing
job I thought
the show was called is that true
is that true on CBS
look honey I love you is that true
[Music]
[Laughter]
not anymore it was it was a show called
I hate my teenage daughter which is is
just as crazy the name is is that true
maybe more crazy it's a little more okay
it was a high concept title
but um
Jamie Presley do you know who that is
yes she was the lead yes and as such it
was sort of a fancy show I mean they
were sort of winding and dining are a
big start with the show meaning or maybe
it was just sitcoms at the time all I'm
saying is oh yeah there was none of this
on old holmese's show right which we
have to talk about that no yes no oh we
do
in their dressing I don't know if it was
J it might have been the producer's
screening room okay like their little
green room with the fanciest food and it
was always Sushi from um
yeah and no one ate it no one eats it no
one eats it no one eats it and as soon
as they left me and the other staff
writers the lowest writers would just
move in and around and it was the best
the best and it was a little warm and we
didn't care no we don't care we don't
care salmonella Manila you mean that eel
sauce I'm gonna put on a non-neal roll
yeah I don't give a [__] on my nipples
put
I don't care old dude nipples nipples
um
Yoko
no no no
the Italian Yoko Ono she broke up the
Beatles with carbs
[Laughter]
okay sorry
um all right
have you ever almost died
just now what if there was like a knife
in this and I mean um have I almost died
you know every 19th my pillow has a
knife in it
that would keep things interesting
nobody Minds
um it's a bonus
got to a point where he was like I think
I can say whatever the [__] okay
my pillow my opinion anyway what is my
opinion hey before we talk about uh when
you almost done me almost dying I do
want to say I was such a huge fan of
crashing oh thank you to the point that
I was
emailing Judd uh going like hey bud I
would have loved you just hanging around
just want to let you know how much I'm
digging the show oh Season Two Season
Two I did and I didn't do that with any
other project that's such a great
compliment my small face to you
compliment earlier I think this is even
greater for me I love that really it
means a lot I don't know why he didn't
mention it probably because you go to
school he's like go right to speak I go
right to spam no not spam blocked
blocked every once in a while after
Wanderlust after love he's like you're
out you're gone you know Wanderlust is
like you had a chance
it is yeah it's a fun movie and so Ken
who put us in touch yes we talked quite
a bit about one or less and David Wayne
it was the greatest experience I believe
it ever it seems like it would be you
know what's can I just jump right yeah
I wish you had been on crashing
second yeah let's get that out of the
way that is one of those movies that
first of all like commune living I'm not
saying I want to live in a commune yeah
I am saying that you look at like
certain parts of Switzerland where
they're doing it in more reasonable ways
where you have your private area but
there's communal this communal that
kibbutz is stuff like that like
basically the whole premise of wework
right right well I know that one but I'm
just saying one of the things that's
lacking in modern culture is community
especially with childbearing child
rearing like like women should not be
raised on your children alone 100 and
I'm gonna say that men who are I'll
speak for myself it can be less
easy for us to share things that are
hard for us but they so many of them
would be solved by having community
community yeah I'm worried about this
I've been through that right yeah now we
can help each other right but men are
just like the Western we want to be
Captain America we want to be Spider-Man
these are all lone wolves Batman these
are all lone walls that's like that is
our mythology
um I don't even like X-Men because I
don't like Ensemble crime fighting I
don't want to but but there's so much so
anyway so you don't want to live in a
crime fighting conference no okay
because I was gonna I had a flyer I was
okay and also communes need to get their
[__] straight about I always say this
but guns and sex like like get the rules
out about guns and sex
I'm talking about religious cults oh
okay which is communal living
and now I'm going to put it to you but
like it seemed like making that movie if
you make a movie about a commune you're
sort of in a mini commune meaning it's a
little bit like summer camp
living in that we lived it yeah we lived
in that house essentially yeah they we
each had a lake home
oh wow
that's a great selling point every night
we would go to one of the houses usually
Paul Rudd's or Jennifer's yeah and we
would we hired a KJ almost every night
karaoke
jukebox uh uh uh uh a karaoke yeah a
karaoke person would come with their
setup
and sort of sit back and sometimes not
sit back and sometimes we join in
um
we heard the rose a lot
sometimes I love the rose for real every
once in a while if you haven't heard the
rose and I'm going to say two years I've
seen it I built into my car every now
and then yeah yeah the bitter snow but
we had the [__] Time Of Our
Lives I mean Jordan peel Catherine Hahn
David Wayne yeah it was ridiculous yeah
Michaela Watkins wasn't we didn't get to
play with Michaela or Michael black or
Michael they were that's a shame uh Ken
was there because he was you know had
co-writer exactly yeah but uh we didn't
get to play with those other guys but
yes
with a synthetic penis that was a big
issue the synthetic penis yeah I believe
it's David Wayne that I talked to about
his fake penis because I was like is
that it was off pudding and it looked
like he had the most enormous pubic
Thicket
I have many pictures which cracks me up
because you know how like you're you're
I don't know like your Apple TV your
pictures will go past it every now and
then one of just this and me like oh my
God with my face you're like in an Al
Franken canceled photo yeah yeah
by the Christmas tree in third grade you
know
equally thick
the thicket is indistinguishable in that
year a really
aggressive oh my God yeah just like the
three wise men gold frankincense
American
exactly we like to keep it you are the
same time to play around yeah I remember
Tour de France I remember gold
frankincense American there have been so
much and I'm really enjoying it okay so
I'm so glad you loved it I just think
it's one of the most underrated comedies
of all time and when Judd did the
podcast the first time which led to
crashing yeah I said why wasn't
Wanderlust a bigger hit that was one of
my questions yes and he said because of
Gary Kenny might have been Jerry Carrie
Kenny yeah probably was he said Jerry I
was like your brother no he said he
thought the title might have been wrong
I agree yeah I agree because if it had
been called like hippie commune or like
[__] Alan Alda so good all in all the
worst it's the best oh I love him I
still we text you text weekly email oh
my God I mean come on I never do this
would he do this or is he too is he
passed through it I don't know because
it seems like at a certainly I almost
hope for him yeah not because of his age
that he's just kind of like uh I don't
know I don't need to uh go around and do
things I don't think he would say that
and I love you but that was a terrible
I'm gonna try again that was my first
impersonation my first try yeah
I've got to let you know friend don't do
that again I feel like it's okay
are you serious we're thinking of the
same person here here here here is that
from Mash we're gonna we're gonna fix
this
no the first thing that comes up by the
way all right here's Alan all the
talking no commercials you don't get a
free commercial online story actually
about his audiobook he wrote a book yes
and I was like so oh this is him
revealing his Parkinson's diagnosis
Jesus We're Not Gonna forget it forget
it I'm bad at the impression I can't fix
it that's fine why of all the videos
reveals I didn't know yet he's this
great impersonation of alcohol
like
that's very one-man show that is so
funny by the way if you audition for SNL
doing impressions of of actors
celebrities but only at their worst
moment and it's like not funny worst
moment like a real and more Michael's
just like their child overdosing yeah
they're finding their dead child yes the
worst things imaginable and Lauren
Michaels is just like but they're the
best impression that was a little bit
like my SNL audition it was what did you
did I don't remember but you did poorly
I don't know I don't think I did poorly
I don't recall feeling like I did poorly
they reached out to me so it couldn't
have been it wasn't couldn't have been
too bad yeah okay but it was during the
state and I was like well all right
we'll try this and I auditioned and I
remember being terrifying I don't
remember feeling like it was bad but
that was a year I believe that they
didn't take anybody new or women or
something that's interesting the whole
experience was not terrible yes but I do
remember it being very frightening but I
think they design it to be frightening
you're told yeah you're told before you
go in there will be no reaction yeah
which is hard which is hard to see how
we started this podcast don't worry we
know what's funny it's like right but
it's also like why I got I mean let's be
honest
obh I like you know I don't what are we
being honest about oh I like a laugh I
like an audience
are you liking this it's like having
someone audition for a jazz band with a
saxophone but the buttons aren't hooked
up you know there's no connective yeah
it's like you're just
but they're like good fingering that's
what it is don't you understand that I'm
a a conductor of laughter right and like
and you're just like yeah but do it
without the laugh I'm not just blowing
Reeds here what am I blowing Reeds
that's the origin of that it happened
right now so when people from now on use
the phrase blow and reads but they're
gonna say what's the entomology of that
phrase ah etymology 20 etymology 2022
podcast
correcting you in real time yeah this
podcast 2023 yes by the way if anyone
comedians listen to the show if anyone
does get SNL and they're eating [__] yes
and you say what are my blown reads
and then you become a huge celebrity on
SNL and then we look up your audition on
YouTube and we're we're both very old
and we play it and we go what am I
blowing leads I'll be so old I'll have
no memory of it that's a weird way to
end the story no I'll be really happy
I'll be really happy and then we'll all
be dead and then we'll all be dead
because they'll be like is that the
podcast where Pete Holmes was making fun
of Alan alda's Parkinson's oh my God
yeah they just do they somehow squish
those two things together and be like
homes taking shots what oh I did a bad
impression and then I found a video and
it was an unfortunate video first he
made fun of her because she was tall the
minute she walked in the door and it was
all downhill from there if you're tall
and you point out someone else is
telling us you can just assume they're
going so tall is always a compliment
it's always a comfortable
Frankenstein's monster
that's something he also does no that's
just you you might see each other in a
grocery store for the first time and
just because we're tall we both sort of
like yeah
uh how tall is your husband
five see ten yeah two talls can't be
together he's not crazy go around
looking like the number 11. right
on the number 11. am I right I mean
what's the deal is that your Allen all
that what this is my Jerry's eye belt
what's the deal we'll be walking around
look at some couples look like 88.
little squabble looking like 11. maybe
11 things going too far looks like
double zero tonight ladies and gentlemen
one night only Pete holmesanalda Kenny
that's Jerry Seinfeld the most mediocre
you got bad posture like come on you
look like 22. come on that's good
a two does look like a swan mm-hmm
and the three is half an eight why why
is no one talking about it why is it
about this W is W
with that it's too late to fix it
although we fixed daylight savings
apparently what can we fix the W did we
get rid of it we just went through it it
is also a WV if you're doing yours is
that it's cursive my son cannot read
cursive I have a 17 year old kid he
can't recursive anytime he gets a
Christmas card from the family you can't
read it
there's got to be an app for that
curso
are you feeling cursed yeah tell me when
you almost died
oh it turns out it turns out I didn't
almost die but I thought I was
um
do you remember okay in the night late
90s I was on a date
and my chest started hurting
and I was like this is weird
um this never happened before I'm 27
years old whatever you know but I am
smoker and I'm you know whatever that's
the brief times in my life where I would
be on cigarettes you'd feel something in
your leg and you're like yeah this is it
this is it that's like that's the one
never told you Joe Campbell never said
like enjoy my product also anytime you
feel something in your neck you'll just
be like this is it you're probably gonna
constantly think you're dying it's not
worth it right okay but I felt that
I went back to my apartment in the
middle of the night my left arm went
numb my chest hurt I thought oh I'm
actually having a heart attack I called
my mom which of course you know made her
feel great first call always Mom first
call always because you want to say
should I call 911 because it happened
and then it ended and I called her I
said Mom it's a Friday night New York
City
do I go to the Urgent to the hospital
meaning there's going to be the Jets I
feel fine what could this be
she she do you mean the Jets like it's
okay
oh she's got chest pain I got a
switchblade in my game yeah see yeah
um yes that's why yeah you didn't want
to go because it'll be busy because of
the Jets isn't that a crazy
consideration you're like no but for
real this is New York City in the 1990s
Saint Vincent's Hospital on Friday night
yeah like you could get killed going in
the door yeah and luckily you're at the
hospital right and you're already there
okay I'm the best place to be so she
said actually
no you wait until
tomorrow you call the doctor's emergency
line if you're feeling fine honey I
sounds like you had a gas pain or you
had a whatever pain because I was fine
great so I did
the next morning
I attend tonight for your mom because
you know now being a mom I know she was
just freestyling she hangs up and then
she was like
hope that was totally and honestly I
don't think it was next morning I think
it was a couple hours later a few hours
later I was like okay
now I'm probably having a panic attack
anyway I go to the hospital oh you do I
go to the hospital it comes back St
Vincent's it comes back I go to the
hospital
my mom comes in from Connecticut
and on a horse on a horse she rides in
on a horse I need to go into the city
with she says to the horse please
Charles Charles take me to the city the
noise is named Charles to the hospital
please I'm saying for instance it seems
my daughter is expiring
[Music]
so they do some tests right and
they sit me down
and my mother down and they say it seems
as though you have a tear in your aorta
we are going to admit you immediately
for open heart surgery
so they call my father he has a pager
he's like in Connecticut he says you
don't open up my daughter till I get
there meanwhile he's calling around to
like top heart surgeons in the city blah
blah luckily
they bought us some time and we call I
tell the story because it's actually
kind of funny parts of this are funny
I said Mom call the state and these are
my brothers so you know I'm like time is
weird in my memory but I look up at one
point in the whole state is standing
there I would have loved to seen the
phone call but only from her side yes
where she's just like okay yeah no it's
a funny riff yeah oh nope sorry there's
more of you
that does sound like me
um but okay hi hi Mike okay oh yep other
mic oh do I have all three mics okay can
I have yep Neil Brennan three mics
please okay go on so um
very long story short they uh that
year
Jonathan Larson who wrote rent
had come to that hospital complaining of
chest pains
they sent him home
and he died of a tyranny's in his aorta
I didn't know that that was not in tick
tick
boom
so a little trivia for you
so they thought oh my gosh here's a 27
year old
they they did a CAT scan and they saw a
shadow and they did a heart monitor and
they heard something and they thought oh
my gosh
we're not going to lose another one to
this
we caught it we're going to do open
heart surgery they're they're writing on
my chest we're ready to go the state is
there I'm like I love I'm gonna die are
we doing bits we're not doing bits yeah
although actually lies I was doing bits
at one point I did this bit where I go
and then I'd watch my heart rate go and
then I'd watch nurses run in my mom was
like you can't do that wait you held
your breath that doesn't stop your heart
though no but I try and get my I go like
oh
and then that might watch my heart rate
go and then they'd come in like a shoe
because I felt fine that's a hard bit
doing this to the end you gotta remember
this is the lady who did miss pills this
lady does not mess around you're erasing
your own charge to the end but I'm going
down wait a minute go down with the beds
so because we waited for so long
this guy did this doctor comes in he
does a trans epigeal cardiogram where
they put a hose in your chest and they
look at the back of your heart you mean
down your throat down your throat and
he's like pull it out pull it out I want
to talk to the doctors they go off in a
corner one nurse comes back and says
take some Tylenol go home come back in
the morning we'll do more tests to find
out what was happening with you it's not
your heart
I had gallstones
gall
the gall the gall the girl in your chest
no when they're passing it mimics heart
attack and the shadow that the thing
they saw in the CAT scan was a shadow
and the heart monitor thing was just
like a sloppy heart valve because I'm
tall and skinny and I went back in had
my my gallbladder out like Bing Bang
Boom no big deal but so I wasn't about
to die
but I I thought I was gonna and when you
thought you were over today it's super
scary or did you just no like full of
love I mean it was yeah it would be it
was I was surrounded by everyone that I
loved and um
just then just total embarrassment
afterwards of like sorry I just passing
a stone yeah speaking of what did they
do that on it was an apple Town movie
where someone just has gas
was it knocked up or was it in no it was
in something yeah I think I do yeah
there's some movie where a woman no it
was an episode of Louis oh okay Scandal
noted I should just say scandals just
sure meaning the Creator's Channel
um have you ever seen a ghost you seem
like someone who's seen a ghost why do
you say that I don't know for some
reasons you have candles
the horse Charlie the horse goes by
Charlie Horse you what about me says I
wear nightgowns I mean Connecticut
oh really yeah long doily kind of
frilled at the edges long like to the
ankle wow like it's almost like wearing
a sleeping bag wow so you shimmy so I'm
like Cindy Lou Who yeah like Cindy Lou
Who I actually just realized I was
picturing Cindy Lou Who this whole time
that's more of a compliment yeah okay so
you seem like a real Lulu right have you
ever seen a ghost
I don't know why I just let's maybe I'll
rephrase it okay if you have there's no
one I'd rather hear about it from than
you that's a nicer way of putting it you
can't walk this back I'm not a I don't
wear long again
uh I
um I haven't seen a ghost I feel like my
that's so boring but I feel like my mom
is like around and it's I feel like in a
lot of bird oh yeah stuff going on I
still feel a connection to your mom yes
but I don't I haven't like seen her in
her nightgown like she's shimmying down
yeah Corridor yes but this is the thing
people say to me like has your mom
visited you or have you I go you know
what I think my mom knows that I would
lose my [__] so I think she's probably
like hanging back because it's not for
me the like I don't need that right it's
like she your mom is looking at a
Netflix for the afterlife yes and
there's her daughter but then it says
warning yeah no thank you she's gonna
lose thank you to the ghosts so she's
just not doing that no that's I don't
think that's that weird by the way yeah
I'm sort of of the opinion that there's
nowhere to go
yeah yeah and also it sounds really
depressing oh no I mean
maybe this is too weird I think
everything's happening all at once yeah
so I think like literally we lose people
but they're still yeah here because
this is too weird for me I don't know
we're having such a nice chat I don't
want to go too weird I just want I don't
want you to think it's weird yeah no I
don't think it's weird I don't think
it's weird at all and I love to hear
other
opinions like that and I think it is
because I'm getting older you know I
really do I wouldn't say like sense of
mortality in that that's not that heavy
yeah but it does I never really thought
about these things like really thought
about them because you're younger you're
like uh you know we're driving too fast
with the lights off and I'm high as a
kite I'm just kidding um I've got a
hooker in the trunk you know you do that
every Saturday I heard a story every
Saturday we'll get to mortality that you
stole a car but somebody was in the car
wait what I heard a story that you stole
a car and somebody was in the car unless
it was a bit oh it was a [__] oh it was
a bit you're such a good actor this
isn't just because I'm embarrassed that
I fell for it but you said it really
convincingly well I get paid for that
yeah not a lot not today enough not
today oh is this not we'll talk about it
you walk out
um yeah uh I gotta go yeah
uh I'm sorry I I'm sorry go ahead we're
talking about mortality because at the
end of the podcast is we do talk about a
little bit about the meaning of life but
let's take our pressure hats off and
just say just today yes that's the whole
thing we won't have to figure it out
just how are you feeling about it today
mortality origin of Life Is there any
sort of
um
God is such a complicated word but do
you have any framework for the for the
universe random benevolent I kind of
feel like the more time goes on the less
I know and I hate sayings like that but
I don't mean it to be a saying
I really do I think I expected that with
adulthood and maturity and by that I
just mean years would come a calm or an
understanding but that has not happened
for me and I feel like what's happened
is more questions and I think that's
just because by Nature I'm closer to it
I mean I would hope that I have a long
way to go but I think it's because I've
never really put my mind to it as a
younger person and as I've gotten older
now I think oh what is that going to
look like and I think it's having lost a
parent too and having been there for it
yes I remember somebody was like your
mom is at the doorway into reality so
when yes if you walk through a door into
a weird universe and then the door I'm
not trying to make you sad yeah
the door vanishes and you're like yes
that's how I came in yes that's like a
week yes 100 that's a beautiful way to
put it yeah that's a beautiful way to
put it and look it's a universal it's
Universal and it's supposed to happen I
hate to say that you know I don't say
that to people who've lost a parent like
it was supposed to happen yeah hey
Dingus but it is it's supposed to happen
and and that definitely opens up a thing
of like oh okay that's gonna happen at
some point and that's a gift too from
your mom yes honestly is like well
there's safety now on the other side too
also something which I never thought
feeling I never thought before it's not
there's not an abyss anymore there's
something maybe there okay you know what
I've been trying to make funny which I
can't
I'm going to say it really quickly
because when I try to say it I say it's
too long okay The Big Bang Theory says
and by measuring radiation there was a
singularity that erupted out of nothing
but and then when we die we go into
nothing and what we seem to think that
that nothing is the end but then the
nothing of the Big Bang was the
beginning do you understand what I'm
saying yeah like it's the same nothing
which isn't empty space it's zero it's
it's incomprehensible like we can't
picture it we can't even prove it yes
like there's no evidence of nothing in
the universe it's kind of like zero it's
a theory yeah it's not a theory there's
evidence of its effects right so you die
you go into nothing and we're all like
it's the end and I'm like except when it
was the beginning that's right so it's
the same people that will tell you be
afraid like be like a materialist and
I'm not saying that looking down my nose
I'm saying a non-spiritual person says
when you die you go into nothing and
it's over we'll also tell you in the
same conversation that nothing was the
beginning right so it's the end except
when it's the beginning and it's nothing
except when it's everything right
everything well my my feeling about it
is this
we can't know nobody knows someone says
they know they don't know yes nobody
knows nobody knows therefore why not
just choose to believe that whatever it
is is a good thing yeah because at the
point you can be waiting in line to see
a show and you can be thinking this is
going to be a bad show the show's going
to be bad it's going to be a bad show
we're gonna pay all this money it's a
bad show why are we wasting time it's a
bad show you go in and the show's bad
okay well you just wasted the whole time
in line saying this is going to be bad
that's right if we keep saying or if I
say oh this isn't going to be good
what's on the other side of this is
going to be scary that's going to happen
it doesn't matter what's going to happen
next or not happen next so why not spend
this time saying maybe this is maybe
it's okay maybe something to be afraid
of maybe this is I will say everything's
going to be okay I'm more worried about
who we're who you leave yeah well that's
beautiful as a parent you can't help but
not feel that way thing for sure I will
say without getting all into it I happen
to love this stuff
and I've got to let's just say it this
way the most simple way I can say it all
of the Masters that I love that you just
get that intuitive sense like this
person has experienced something and
they're sharing it
um they would all agree that there's
nothing to worry about right
as Richard door says all the mystics
meet a lover not a uh Tormentor right
like that's an authentic God experiences
when you meet and you here's I'm gonna
actually bring it a little bit down to
earth is that when you are calm it might
be after a cigarette when you were young
might be after sex it might be after
sleep or a good meal or you're looking
at that Lake we're shooting Wanderlust
when you are reduced to a thoughtless
point of awareness
when you investigate that awareness it's
actually more it's not just a blank
slate it's not just nothing you're not
just a computer that with no impetus
you're sitting around doing nothing
you're resting state when examined and
you're not thinking about your life
situation isn't just blank it's actually
joyful it's actually Blissful right it's
actually loving right and if you don't
I'm not saying you if you don't believe
me I would recommend doing some breath
work right breath exercises some
meditation not not just for the
discipline of it but to actually
experience your true nature I'll explain
it real quick just just in case it's the
first episode anyone's listened to Val
and I my wife and I talk about this on
Friday there's a type of breath work you
can lay down just put on some music and
do this for 20 minutes you breathe in
your stomach like that and then the
second part you're breathing into your
chest is more like a yawn is like
so it's a really when you start doing
that you realize you've never taken a
deep breath before right you're always
just doing it right so it's one two
do that for 15 minutes 20 minutes
um at the end of it you will love
everyone yeah and it's not just because
you're high I actually think it quells
those thoughts that say Carrie you're
not good enough Carrie God is mad at you
your dad is mad at you the world is mad
at you uh the Earth is mad at you the
universe is mad at you you you dissolve
your thoughts and you get into that
state and that isn't you don't have to
take someone else's word for it you can
go that is a very good clue that the
irreducible nature of all things was
more like that space right and less like
all of the neuroses that you'd be
inhuman to not have them of course
you're like I'm a bad boy I'm a I'm evil
I'm wrong I'm ugly I'm I'm a a reject or
whatever but when you shut your brain
off what's left is often very clear and
I'm I'm look I don't know but for us
today because I have death anxiety as
well for us today I'm like I'm pretty
sure
death is is a return to that right place
not
shooting they're not shooting there it's
more of a I was there the whole time
yeah yeah I suspect it is I suspect it
is and also it if it isn't
there's nothing
I mean if it does come down to that
moment and we're in like a fiery Hell
Fire oh it's like well I wasn't there's
nothing to prepare anyways
where are you going well I the the
concept of hell is is so psychologically
obvious to me that yeah that like
Freudian like Freud was on to this
unconscious guilt yeah
um I've been looking at A Course in
Miracles they they addressed that to
unconscious guilt I'm like it is there
right like we all somewhere in an
undiscussed part of our psyche feel like
we're lost in the woods right with a
broken leg and there's wolves after us
right like and no one talks about it
right but we're just dealing with that
and of course that experience leads to
talking about a God that hates us that
hates everything you've ever done right
that you smoke cigarettes or whatever
you did that you stole that car that you
didn't really steal I love it I gotta
know where that came from Comedy said it
was a video online usually I just type
the person's name I know what this is I
know what this is this was a um this was
press yeah for uh our last season cribs
on not on quibs but God I love you say
quiz my son makes fun of me all the time
he goes we we're in the grocery store
he's like I think somebody recognizes
Carrie Kenny from quibby I'm like that
is a great job how is it 17. that's good
stuff
um that's I mean but you can't hate them
I mean it's the low-hanging quibby on
the tree
um
but I don't remember my point was we
were just saying
I'll get there I'm the host yes
uh
uh oh man
we're talking about
there being nothing to be afraid of yes
I was saying guilt unconscious guilt oh
yes and we make a God that mirrors us we
make God in our image instead of I do
find it really funny that we walk around
I don't know funny is the right word but
we walk around with these like computers
in our these [__] busy
punishing Unstoppable like even in our
dreams we can't get a break he's
deciding I'm making the see that there's
a candle on this here's the temperature
what am I gonna have for lunch just all
of it yes
um and I do suspect because when I do
meditation or when I found that place in
you know church with my family or
synagogue with my husband and son or any
any of these places where I find those
moments
um I do believe that you're right that
that's the true uh Essence that that's
the true the other stuff is static on
the radio all static on the radio that's
a great way to put the song isn't coming
in and I suspect that the it's it will
be some sort of turning of the knob
where the static goes away what okay I
have to say this with respect because I
believed that there was a God that
wanted to torment you so I I don't want
to put down that right if that's your
belief I grew up methodists so we didn't
really have all that okay it was very
very different
God bless maybe I just wasn't paying
attention yeah yeah you weren't there
that one week all right Carrie's not
here let's do that how about the lake of
blood or whatever it is I I just so I
don't want to be dismissive I just want
to say it does you know what I equate it
to you know on on Twitter or Instagram
they'll do like the draw Shrek challenge
or something right or Draw Gonzo in The
Muppets and people post like without
looking forward to me when you said
drugonzo but go ahead or you know like
Drop God you know Gonzo Gonzo
never how dare you I didn't like when
you said I'm not the pretty girl earlier
I almost stopped you but I was like
she's making a point let's let's set
this one out it's a good point no stop
it I feel like I just wish I could be a
stereotypical game male sidekick
sometimes and just be like you're
gorgeous you are a very stereotypical
gay man that's what I've always said
completely
like a sidekick on sex in the city right
uh
what was it oh so that when people have
to draw Gonzo or Shrek by memory right
and it's terrible terrible and they're
so funny yeah I think spiritual reality
I know this sounds a little bit yeah
is like that you can't draw Shrek from
memory but you can look at 500 of them
and know they're wrong right you know
what I'm saying right and when you see
real Shrek you go that Shrek right and
when you talk about a God who made you
to test you to then punish you eternally
yeah I go that looks like a bad Shrek to
me yeah or his father Greg Boyle would
say wrong God yeah he's wrong God it
sounds made it sounds made up it sounds
derived from Fear it's a fear choice and
I relate right and I get that there's
even a perverse I don't want to say
perverse but a pleasure yes in being
like I'm a naughty boy yes and we're all
Naughty Boys it's also scapegoating
especially if you think other people are
going to hell and you're not you can go
the guilts over there right I did my
side of the street is clean that's right
I believe that we are
aside from whatever sort of mystical
dust or you know part of the Big Bang
Yes all of those things I think more
than anything we are the stories that
people tell about us once we're gone so
I made it a point with my son I have one
child it's my mother's only grandchild
so I talk about her a lot and I once
said to him you know in case you're
wondering why mommy talks about Grandy
all the time it's because we are the
only way she stays alive right she's
only got her sister who's still alive
and that's it and me and my son that's
interesting
I'm also going to join in and say that
also genetically
like your
son or half of your son was in your
mother's womb yes right you already know
this fact right with all your eggs yes
which is crazy when you look at your
baby girl exactly no my daughter was
inside my mother-in-law and that
is hot it's really hot
I just ruined everything
dudes it's a challenge to not have the
meaning of life section be too serious
so I applaud and I I award you a quibby
for that for that for that
for the last year of cable Ace Awards
too so I am just across the board losing
all the things can you please in your
house yes have like a shelf where like
as you first walk in you go it's my
cable Choice whatever it is I have my
certif Miami nomination certificates all
five of them which are basically they
might as well be like you lost you lost
you lost you lost so I laugh at them
they're in my office I laugh at them
it's an eye I wish I had my second City
rejection letter not that they'd be
begging for me now I'm just saying like
it was nice that I didn't quit you know
right that's all right
I had I got rid of it years ago and I
really wish I hadn't but Tom Lennon Ben
Grant and Michael Ian Black made for me
a cable Ace award out of spray painted
macaroni
the year that I lost Cassandra Oh yes
and
they haven't stopped crying calling
Sandro yeah they sent me faxes from the
desk of Sandra Oh in our office so we're
you know doing Viva variety and I kept
getting they're like another facts for
you and it said from the desk of Sandra
Oh you're a terrible actress from the
desk of Sandra Oh you should give it up
now from this is so good so good oh my
God love it need it obviously not from
the real desk of Sandro nobody thought
okay nobody because that would be
terrible oh God Sandra's a friend okay I
wish she was
um this was Delight here's the fine
which is not even finishing my words
anymore Here's the final question yes
okay seriously have you seen it goes I'm
just kidding did you murder someone are
they in the truck okay no because the
cops are here and
that would be the best way to end it
like cheaters see that's why the the
hell God is also why we love public
trials right catching things cheaters
Judge Judy we love it yeah because as
long as the guilt is out there sure you
don't have to look at your own shame
well it's all that stuff that that
Tick-Tock stuff of like outing people oh
yeah and yes it's good to keep Community
Watch for sure there's some Joy some
endorphin rush going for people of the
people from hurting other people is very
different from going oh good we got that
cheater yeah but not looking at how how
am I cheating I don't I don't cheat on
my wife but like how am I being
dishonest right but instead I go like at
least I'm not that guy getting right of
course of course welcome back to Dr Phil
Welcome Back Cotter I think we're all
thinking here's Dr Phil right you know
he was the original cutter I'm just my
god
um it's the best crossover ever Cotter
Cotter you ate a lot of cod right but
that doesn't sound right does it anymore
Cotter you're too young for Welcome Back
Cotter I remember welcome back
yes up your nose with a rubber hose did
you have a t-shirt no I just had a nose
up my hose [__] oh
friend do it again should I come in
again yeah yeah let's start over Okay
but do give me a take two okay did you
have the T-shirt
see I just fooled you with my good
acting
you say I'll say up your nose with a
rubber hose then you say looking at the
T-shirt up your nose with the rubber
Rose did you have the T-shirt no I just
had a rubber nose at my house okay
[Laughter]
we have lunch can we push lunch okay
okay we're in penalty we're in
Pennsylvania we'll keep rolling we'll
get it no
we already cut [__]
[__] I know we're losing light it's fine
we'll do it I'll do it as Eleanor then
Here's the final question okay can you
tell me and it's I always say the same
thing it doesn't have to be a great
story so this is not a pressure moment
well great you've come to the right lady
just think of a time in your life maybe
the time you laughed the hardest you've
ever left okay but does it come up oh
yeah oh no without it out without a
doubt yes
I think a lot I don't know if anyone on
this couch has ever said this before if
you've had other state members I know
you had Michael Showalter Wayne David
Wayne I had Mike black why am I last why
am I
uh anyway we don't have to get into that
no it's been I've never had 30 of us and
I'm okay good well fine and who else are
we forgetting
um Michael black Michael Showalter
um David Wayne Michael Jan David Wayne
Ken Moreno Kevin Allison I haven't had
Kevin Allison Todd hollaback who started
the group he lives in South Korea good
luck getting him although he might fly
out here it's not North Korea um it's
true uh I'm sure I'm forgetting someone
David Wayne Marshall whatever quit
complaining guys there's 11 of us okay
quit complaining about it there's three
Michaels
um
oh
we were doing a shoot in New Jersey I
think because we used to shoot on
location half location half on uh in a
studio we were doing a location shoot
and we it was very Bare Bones I'm sure
you could tell uh we did the props we
did I was 13. we did wow
that's how we felt too yeah and uh we
made four dollars and we traveled around
in and like with you know my mom's
clothes were the costumes for the ladies
and wow you know we did we it was
amazing yeah but uh it was definitely
like a we're putting on a show in a barn
kind of vibe yes and we had been
shooting for I want to say 30 hours one
day
um that's accurate and uh we were
exhausted I feel like covered in mud for
some reason
um and we had stopped at a roadside like
Greek diner or something like that in
Jersey on our way back to the city and
it just was a horrible
horrible experience like nothing none of
the orders were right everybody was
starving the bathroom was out of War
it's just like everything was wrong and
we were over
it and we got in the car in the van and
everyone's chain smoking and I remember
Tom threw a cigarette out the front
window and David Wayne was sitting like
this with his knees up on the the
um Dash no no like the seat in front of
him his knees and he's wearing like
little like Runners shorts and the
cigarette went out the window and down
traveled down the back
it was just like it was one of those
like it was one of those nights where
you're just like [__] and I just
remember somebody
we got back in the van somebody just
started yelling and
somewhat joined it we all joined in and
it was a I want to say a 30 minute
cathartic Primal scream Primal scream
yeah Primal scream like you could have
heard that van coming you would have
been like
Scooby-Doo we yelled till our throats
were yeah and then laugh laughing like
peeing ourselves just laughing laughing
Space Mountain Space Mountain
I it was the most cathartic like I felt
like whatever you know 23 years of junk
that had piled up the drain was opened
and cleaned and flushed
and I will never and I've been it like a
junkie I've been you've been chasing it
chasing it yeah it's I you can't make
that happen nope you need the back you
need all the frustration to Justified
and motivate and Empower it and then
when it happens the release but then
also Imagine 10 male voices
who are your brothers
that sound and the the I'll just never
forget it of course yeah I love it I
feel like I was there yeah you might
have been there there was a lot of white
men you might have been one I think you
were one you were great in that one
sketch about them oh my God if I could
have just walked by in my rayon shirt
well yeah you were 13 it might have been
odd yeah it would have been weird yeah
what's he can sag rolls you guys are
working 30 hour days I don't think I
could have been there
uh I I'm not going to tell the whole
story because I've told it before but
sometimes my opener and I would yell in
the car just like too many shows you on
purpose like you like a primal scream
like but you would say like we did this
as an exercise from list the Listerine
commercials so we go
and we would weep with laughter just too
many planes yeah too many clubs too many
planes yeah too much having to follow
the rules that was me and Chris there
yeah yeah I call them my opener yeah my
errand boy I can yes it's the best it's
the best all the time I've tried it
since then I yelled in my car a couple
days ago yeah out of like it was like a
sitcom exasper I hung up the phone
someone was bugging me and I hung up the
phone and I did the best that's what
it's for yeah it's a little isolated
chamber on Wheels yeah the new Ford Fury
[Laughter]
actually that is a sketch that I've
always wanted to do it's called the
polite phone me and Oren Brimmer my
creative partner uh we wrote it together
and it's a phone that translates what
you want like into something like so
you're like I'll be there when I [__]
be there honey and it goes I'm so sorry
my love I'm running a bit late please
keep dinner have dinner without me did
the ATT polite phone that's great I feel
like that's an app away
yeah well we haven't already
I have a thing and we'll wrap up here
but like I have a thing where I do
sometimes go back in my emails and add
the pleases and thank yous I'll go like
if we could have the electrician be
there tomorrow that would be great like
it's still a polite not after you send
it no no not after I send it and then I
go like oh if we could please have the
electrician be there those are easy ones
to forget because your ending on that
would be great that sounds positive but
you're like don't forget to say please
and then I do too many exclamation
that's the thing like did you see the
emails I wrote you okay I know that's
how I knew I would love it
smiley emoji I knew we were cut from the
same place immediately
and when when you wrote the email and
then you immediately were like I forget
it I was like This Is My Jam This Is My
Jam you'd like my wife too she's very
much like that oh boy well I need to
learn how to just let it let it ride but
but you notice it I I thought it was
inherently female but now I know that it
isn't but the reason is because I look
at the state text thread and so every
day someone you know the guys will write
something and like of course Michael
Black can write a joke and it just let
just let it sit just let it sit but then
I have to write like ha ha
and on a group thread don't do the hold
the text and select haha because then it
just goes Carrie Carrie Kenny laughed at
a time I know that it just says it
sometimes I'll just write that all right
but I'll write out beat on SLAP to
detect that's so good I'm stealing that
I am stealing are you gonna add like I'm
doing that today it's a good bit solid
bit Yeah you ever leave a typo in a text
just to show them that you don't really
care no no that's deep that one time I
was taking somebody down I was like I
just wish this person then I could text
you last so I had misspelled something
and I was like just left it you did an
asterisk nope taco no and I didn't do it
answered Saco
Asterix Taco yeah this is my Hulu
password I did not nastrous ducking
ducking
iPhones please please guys just let us
say [__] makes me feel like I'm dirty
also can we see yes it does
it's like the minister in your phone
that would be a good one to text [__]
and then write asterisk ducking I meant
are you gonna meet me at the ducking
restaurant
solid text bet
asterisk ducking my favorite is when you
try to correct it but it keeps doing it
because mine is weird
you could see my dad's frustration build
and build and build in the cutest way
totally can he is this inaccurate I'll
ask you and Katie yeah old people okay I
love replying K the letter K uh no not
my dad well you're dead what are you
asking because we're old no because
Katie is so ancient
no I'm saying because both my mom and my
dad do it they write K just the letter k
no my no I will say this yeah I'll never
be able to prove it there are thousands
of people that are like yes like yelling
at their uh yeah no not my no my dad's a
gray texter we're in a family text
thread every day and wow my dad they're
great they're my family's amazing I get
that feeling yeah that's the good peeps
we're a Fun Bunch must be nice
come on over
tall just another tall tasty dude
Coco Puffs the first time I had him I
was like these could be sweeter like if
you have coconut Bubbles and then you go
to Cocoa Puffs sure you're like oh sure
yeah more of a milk chocolate for sure
cocoa is like old people being like you
have some kicks sprinkle on just raw
cacao powder I taste cocoa
because I have a heads of cocoa
it's a mild cereal is it hazelnut that
I'm tasting no I know what it is it's
cocoa it's the only subtle cereal
there's that cocoa I'm just doing next
actually the next commercial is I'm
cooking for Cocoa Puffs the only subtle
cereal
from the least subtle mascot finally
something for your palette I like
something that's a little subtle
I have cocoa for mouthfeel
any result I bet if I had them now I'd
be like this is the sweetest thing I've
ever seen you would go into like a
diabetic coma for sure probably
I was gonna say I'd call your mom but
your mom is do it well I'd call it and
if she comes back as a ghost don't tell
me because I don't want to know about it
yeah that's right I'm gonna say this for
the record if your mom wants to tell me
something to tell you what if tonight
what if tonight my mom's like don't tell
me anything about her okay because if
I'm like your mom said something and you
start to cry immediately and I'm like
Cheryl said and you're like it's not
[__] Cheryl Sharon Sharon
well you've met Trudy Weigel that's
right enough said
NS
you're doing your mom a little bit just
a tiny tiniest bit the innocent sweet
part of her just the time at the time
has been
then the third way she lives on the
tiniest bit in your son in you in memory
intruding a little bit a little bit
love it yeah all right let's go are we
going no we're out of here oh
going where I don't know I got excited I
just feel like this is the right time to
end yes yes we're gonna ask would you
say it used to be up there keep it
crispy is the is just the science when
you say keep it Christmas I would like
to say something to you and that is this
I'm gonna need you
to keep it crispy
crispy it's one of the things you Rift
on 911 is you're like talk about your
baby you were like if this is a
watermelon it would be eleven dollars
talk about how heavy it is well this is
the beauty
we did the pilot for Reno in the year
2000. it is now
2022. so we
three so we have been uh you know you're
still thinking about how you made that
mistake twice I watched you know you
know what it was I can't tell you know
what it was because we did a joke
yesterday my husband and I were doing a
joke where we were writing a forget it
it's so not funny but anyway yes yes I
was wondering that and then I remembered
that that's why I did it anyway I am
mushrooms
in life
I'm high on life I'm getting that for
your baby I'm high on shrimps all babies
are unsure yes that's why I was such a
good dad because I've trapped trip set
people you gotta put on good music right
get them water every once in a while
same sure my buddy Travis and my baby
same thing right same thing need it dose
them up
[Music]
all right the end